you said jennifer
you're all set yep
so the time's past nine o'clock uh
welcome to the legislative
administration uh quick pledge of
allegiance
representative
i pledge allegiance to the flag
of the united states of america and to
the republic for which it stands one
nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
uh
this will be a
work session my intention i think is to
try to do
um the three bills that we have
outstanding welcome
representative baxter um
the three bills we have outstanding and
i think a work session
on 10 33 for the first
25 minutes or so till 9 30 then if we do
15 minutes each on
12 69
and
1368 right
and then when we get to 10 o'clock i
think we'll be able to
execute these three and be done our
work for this
half of the
second year right good with that anybody
have any concerns comments questions
um with that i think i'll
begin
explaining what we've done
with
house bill 1033
and
i think there's enough copies for
everyone
that wants them either on the table or
we're going to open on 10 33
this is
this was a bill prime sponsor was
representative cordelli
we have a
from our very fine researcher a
legislative history on this
this subject matter
dealing with
state and local funding of
lobbying activities
was last heard in 2020
when and the
the
report out of the senate from senator
levesque
and i'll just grab one sentence out of
here she said while the legislation has
merit
the committee agreed agreed
that there would be
unintended consequences
didn't list them unfortunately
in 2017 there were two
there was also the same bill prohibiting
recipients of county or municipal funds
from using such funds for lobbying
that too
failed
but again funnily enough
there was a sentence in there that said
although the intent of the bill is good
the language and lack of clarity make it
unacceptable
um then in 2014 same thing
2012 same thing and all of them the
common denominator is saying
this is
this is a good idea
so
with that
some of us have taken it upon ourselves
to
clarify some of the language
and it seems to me from
the the
calls and emails i've received there's
an awful lot of misinformation on this
and i think that is due to
the imprecise language
so
which is why i pulled out and made
copies for all of you
section 15 1 and section 15 5.
everybody has a minute can pull those
the calls that i'm getting
are saying if this bill passes
it's going to
shut down free speech from
from the
cities towns
counties
and they won't be able to
um
a track all of the information
for all of the the
bills coming
through the legislature and two they
wouldn't be able to come and talk to us
about it because they would be
prohibited
and i think that comes from that first
line on 15 5
where it says except as provided in
paragraph 2
no recipient of a grant or appropriation
of state funds may use the state funds
to lobby or attempt to influence
legislation
participate in a political activity or
contribute funds to any entity engaged
in these activities
and
i think it's being misinterpreted that
that means if an employee of a community
of a town of a state
or a county um
receives they are recipients of
appropriation of state funds so they
think that that means that they are
prohibited
and
for that i then point you to section 15
and roman
v roman 5
that talks about
who is exempt
to report as a register and report as a
lobbyist
and in that it very clearly says that
public testimony before a legislative
committee is exempt
public testimony for any entity
subject to rsa 91 is exempt
all the way down through
letter
h
are all the exemptions and that covers
all of those people that think
if this bill passes they would be
um
they would be
stopped from from talking to us about
legislation that affects their county
their town their city their anything
and i maintain it does not um
and we've had discussions with our
with our house attorney to that effect
who's also in the room
um
so i think that imprecise language was
what needs to be fixed
we have a an amendment
215 5
that
that is one part of this issue
good morning representatives
um
so
um the replacement for
or what we think for fifteen five
is what where's the
where's the amendment for that
that changes the language of 15 5 and
i'll give you a quick second
the important
part to read is it's saying except in
paragraph two no state grant or
appropriation of funds or funds
collected from property taxes
shall be used to lobby or attempt to
influence legislation participate in
political activity promote or oppose
directly or indirectly any legislation
pending or proposed before the general
court
and and
paragraph two says any entity that
wishes to engage in any of the
activities prohibited in paragraph one
shall segregate the state funds and
funds collected from property taxes
in a separate account in such a manner
that such funds are physically and
financially separate
from any non-state grant and
appropriation or property tax funds that
may be used for any of these purposes
mere bookkeeping separation of the state
funds or funds
funds
that should one should say fund or funds
collected from the property taxes from
other monies shall not be sufficient
so
you'll see that there's a lot of the
similar language
we did not change at all the exemptions
in 1501 so all of those exemptions still
and i think that needs to be
emphasized
that
this is not stopping any free speech
the purpose of this is simply to say
state funds and and funds raised by
local property taxes shall not be used
for under 15
everybody with me so far
the next step to this
is a second amendment
and the reason for the second amendment
that we're
not exactly the reason for doing that um
that other amendment is that
in looking i i
in the conversations i've had
um and maybe some other representatives
can follow follow along with that or
back me up
it seems that um many places aren't even
aware 15 5 exists
or is the current law
so that got us wondering whether
putting those prohibited activities in
the lobbyist section
means that
cities towns counties
never see this prohibited
action
so we started thinking maybe
the logical thing to do would be to put
this prohibited
activity
section
in each of the other parts of the rsas
one dealing with
schools one dealing with county one
dealing with municipal law
so that
they see the prohibited
activities that
pertain to their
daily activity
does that make any sense or is there are
there any good morning
is there any conversation on that we are
the idea would be instead of having it
in lobbyists
here's my quick example
a school board um
that is that is looking through their
section of of
rsas
wouldn't know to think to go into the
lobbyists section to see what were the
prohibited activities
that pertain to
them instead you we're putting that
prohibited activity in their own section
so they would see
because we're really prohibiting
lobbyist activities not
not prohibiting lobbyists
right the lobbyists aren't the ones that
are being prohibited here it's the
county it's the school it's the state
i'm sorry it's the municipalities
the county and the
school departments that are
being prohibited from using those funds
to purchase lobbying services
so that's where the two amendments are
floors open if anybody has conversation
comments concerns
um
but that's that's the purpose and that's
i either did a spectacular job or nobody
are you okay with that are you okay with
that
um i i still have some concerns sure
um because i that's the purpose of the
work session here we've got gotta
out of practice yeah
um
i'm still feeling as though this is an
anti-lobbyist
type of bill
and i look at lobbyists as
professionals who try to help us
with more information on the work that
we do as opposed to
grabbing for
any position or any um
job that they feel they need to do to
be negative
and i'm still having a hard time
accepting
that
a small town such as the towns i
represent
belonging to something like the
municipal association
can't just trust that association to as
part of their work
represent the towns and the jobs that we
do
and what i'm still hearing from
selectmen and town councillors
only in the tenants i represent
is that they're concerned
that with all the bills that come before
us and i think we had testimony that
some 300 bills this year in one way or
another affect our cities and towns
that something may be missed that is
important to these communities
how can a small town
with limited resources
or a city that's very very busy and
can't keep track of everything either
one having their individual
circumstances but problems how can they
have a voice up here
if they don't trust a group like the
municipal association
to do that is only part of the dues that
we pay into them and i need to go back
to the people who have asked me to vote
no to be able to say to them well this
is absolutely the very best way in the
world to solve this help me please sure
hi thank you
i guess the problem that i had when i
was looking at this is that the current
statute
um 15 5
already
prohibits
recipient of grant money or
appropriation of state funds
to use them to either influence
legislation political activity etc so
there's already a prohibition in 15 5.
that language when i looked at this was
very confusing to me and i hope you can
the first line of that 15-5 says except
as provided in paragraph two no
recipient of a
grant so
lobbyists are not necessarily
recipients of grants
and i did not think it was a good idea
to have
lobbyists
in this language as a recipient when we
know
that grants and state funds as well as
property taxes
the recipients of that money are the
towns the counties the municipalities
so i did not want to necessarily say
that a recipient and how that is defined
because it is not
is the lobbyist because it is not the
lobbyist
so that i think that there needed to be
some explanation in the lobbyist statute
they don't know
the lobbyists do not know
whether the funds they're getting are
funds from taxpayers
or from non-taxpayers
how do you fix that
you fix that by putting it in each of
the sections in the statute
for the cities the counties the towns so
that they know they have to separate
them and one thing that was done in the
in the legislation that that we're
looking at
is we clarified how to
separate the funds by putting them in a
separate account
that was never before in any of the
language in the statute
so not only are are we making it clear
this
group of folks
are the recipients
and they must separate funds that are
taxpayer
and that are not in separate accounts
that was added to these bills
so when there's no targeting of
lobbyists but the fact that we had so
many questions coming from town folks
getting to your
questions specifically
none of this prohibits
the the purchasing of lobbying services
right
it's strictly saying
you just can't use these funds to do it
so the second part of your question when
you were talking about how does a small
town do this
um
from testimony we heard that the the
rates changed depending on the size of
the town right
um so we went and started looking at
where could cities and towns
access funds that aren't related to
local property taxes or state
and some of the examples were
they went from the ridiculous to the
sublime i mean you could talk about dog
licenses you could talk about
funds that came in from
recycling of
in my town we recycle cardboard
those are funds that aren't coming from
property taxes i think we only had to
have something like 500 in my town for
our municipal
um association dues
so
it's this this should not be looked at
firms to represent them or
the ability to go through and have a
municipal association not to pick on
them but you brought it up
they can they can assess the bills that
are coming through and and
and it still would be possible
under all of this for any of the town
officials to contact their
representatives
contact or come in themselves and
testify here that's not a prohibition on
there's nothing in any of the existing
law or anything that we're proposing
any of the town employees or any of the
representatives for that
you can't leave the phone on and then
sorry that doesn't work um anyway so
that that's my answer to it
thank you representative hill there's
really two things i want to comment on
one
to me this seems like a house cleaning
effort because section 15 5.
you're blowing everybody out with your
microphone are you saying it's too loud
some people like it some people don't
you can't please everybody coming in
from education saying what the heck is
going on
but um
to me it seems like the intended purpose
of section 15 5
was to make sure that taxpayer funds
aren't going towards lobbyist activity
and so this effort is to try to make
sure that intended purpose is actually
taking place and our laws reflect that
so that's number one that this is really
just cleaning up the the law that's
already supposed to be in place and then
two to the other representative's
question
this bill is not going to get rid of the
municipal association or anything like
that we'll still see them here lobbying
us it just won't be taxpayer funds going
towards the municipal association and i
think a majority of
our constituents whether we're
republicans or democrats would be
horrified if they found out that there
are taxpayer funds going towards
lobbying
some people might not but
i think a lot of folks would be and
that's not to say the municipal
association is good or bad everyone has
a different view
but it just shouldn't be taxpayer funds
that's funding lobbying that's that's it
yeah thank you representative
representative
just clarification on one point um
regardless this bill wouldn't prohibit
a lobbying group such as the municipal
association from researching bills and
informing towns or municipalities about
bills that may or you know may affect
them they just wouldn't be able to lobby
us directly on those things right so
they could pass that information along
so even if towns and municipalities
don't have the resources to track every
single bill that's coming through
uh a lobbyist association could still
research those bills and let them know
hey this is coming up and it might
affect your town is that correct
um
that i mean that'd be that's a question
for clarification yes um go ahead
thank you mr chairman thank you
um
i don't nobody i've ever talked with is
horrified about lobbyists coming in for
cities and towns
the way the communities i represent are
looking at this
and i'm looking at it still
for example when we pay our dues to the
municipal association
part of the job of the municipal
association
is to keep track of what's going on so
that they can better inform the towns
it's not a matter of
the towns
having one issue and the municipal
association having another issue and
then lobbyists come in and fight with
each other or whatever lobbyists do i
don't think they do that but anyway
but anyway i i believe that when a
community pays into their dues to the
municipal association that they're
looking at the municipal association as
a resource
for whatever they need for
information when it comes to legal
issues with employees for example
or when it comes to environmental issues
that may affect communities
things like that
and just part of what the a small part
of what the municipal association does
is they do have a couple of lobbyists
on how do how does anyone who's supposed
to separate it says
mere bookkeeping separation is not going
to work
how does this work i don't understand
how the separation does work now and
what we expect thank you representative
um
actually it's supposed to be occurring
now right i mean from
1505 it's supposed to be being done now
my community when i when i talked to
them
and they were one that came in and
testified on the original bill if you
recall
my
community
sits up my school department as well
sets up a separate account just like
they do when they have trust funds or
anything
they have physically
separated the funds not just in
bookkeeping but they have
created a new checking account or a new
savings at home whatever you want so
that's that's the only separation
representations
thank you mr chair i am
never shy from asking a dumb question
although mr clerk will then say there
are no dumb questions i don't know
um
would there be any unintended
consequences
from this if it passes
that there are i don't know how else to
say it but
sort of like
people who serve in multiple roles
so there were at one point state reps
from concord four of whom were
city councilors
a number of our state reps are also
selectmen
and et cetera are firefighters
is i realize that we're talking about
funds from these entities
but recipients of those funds
cross-pollinate
is there any unintended consequence to
that
thank you for your question do you want
no you're doing good okay
so we um
so what i would encourage and i gave you
a copy there of fifteen 15-1
so 15-1
talks about
who is exempted from registering and
acting as a lobbyist
and so all of those people we believe um
would that you just
highlighted you know someone that acts
as a selectmen or
wouldn't they they obviously don't have
to register as a lobbyist and so that
this would not apply to them
they would still have the ability to
attempt to influence legislation they
would have the ability to come in and
testify they would do everything that
they're currently
exempted from doing under 15 1. so
nothing changes here yep represents
specifically show you where it is roman
numeral five
and a go to d
d is communication made by public
official acting in the official capacity
so that nothing changes from what we're
what this bill does it's already there
for that protection
yep
yes representative
thank you mr chair um
this is a very basic question and i
apologize that i wasn't able to listen
to the first testimony yeah was there a
business manager
um
that testified about the
accounting
implications that
this
would incur
so
as far as additional costs for this
or in terms of actual redundancies of
what this has the potential to create
right um i think that was actually my
town administrator that was here
coincidentally
and i and i have i've had further
conversations um with the selectmen in
town
one of there's two things that i'd like
to point out they're already they're
already supposed to be doing this
number one
number two um
well
number two they weren't aware that they
were already supposed to be doing this
so
that's what led us to the the point that
it's not in the right section you know
fifteen five
deals with lobbyists not with municipal
actions so that's part of the the
separate amendment
on the original bill
which i
i'm hoping everyone has a copy of
there was a fiscal note and the fiscal
note
contacted two agencies to
to create the fiscal note one was the
association of counties and the other
was the municipal association
and if you look at the um under the
methodology of
what the costs would be or either
increase or decrease the municipal
association stated that there would be
no impact at the local level
so that's where that was
the part that i pointed out to my
selectmen
i hope that does that answer what you
were
asking
how to do it or well i asked if there
was actually a business manager the
person that does the math
and creates the budget for that town
administrator and those select
people so i think that would have been
the town administrator that you we were
talking about and my question is do they
have then that capacity what is that
financial impact so you answered that
with through the fiscal note my question
was was there actually someone here or
did we receive testimony from anybody
about what that means in their
day-to-day does their software allow
them to do this it's like a really basic
question well they it should because as
i just said they're doing that with
trust funds and and funds that are
specifically having to be separated now
so i can't imagine that there's a
software package that has to be changed
or i don't know
right yeah yeah if they're dealing with
other with their with their other grants
and things and how it impacts then
their audit like these do have really
um
can have far-reaching accounting
implications and over-complicating
something that they should have simply
been able to already be doing we didn't
have anything what i'm trying to really
be aware of and
and not add the burden to
um smaller towns and
okay i think i i think so we think the
answer is that it shouldn't we have no
testimony that says that that's the case
okay thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and
this is a committee that really works
well together and
i know our chairman tries very hard to
make things right
there's a butt coming here now what
usually usually
so what i'm wondering mr chairman um
because there's a belief that these
amendments may make the bill better
is there anyone we could hear from in
the audience who might have seen these
amendments who might be able to tell us
that this is agreeable or not because
we're talking about something more than
what we heard testimony on
i
have no idea
whether there is a
there is
additional information
that needs to come forward
we we truly are simply
uh changing the language of the existing
law to make it more
clear i believe
and we're trying we're suggesting that
it goes into a
separate each separate section of the
the law so that it pertains to the
specific groups
the
what was the phrase they used the
recipient groups
rather than um having it affect
lobbyists because
it doesn't affect lobbyists
so
follow up sure thank you very much mr
chairman um on our committee records do
we have
the blue sheet who was in favor and who
was opposed do we have anything like
that available i have only from the
original online system
i don't have a blue sheet from here
we did have 21 supporting and 39
opposing
from the original
hearing that we had on the bill
okay follow up sure thank you mr
chairman again um
i think i heard from all 31 of the
opposing quite frankly if you want to
know i believe that
probably
i'm wondering if there's anyone here
today who can
tell us
if they represent we heard some powerful
testimony from the association for
counties and the municipal association
is there anyone here
who can add to this to help those of us
who are concerned
can we certainly offer sure does anybody
have any comments that they would like
maybe not
you're welcome to i mean i'm happy to
obviously i've been listening and taking
if you would like her to i it
we're in a work session so that we fine
thank you
the recordings can't pick up something
right
right we'll get them
just take a moment sure would you would
you take a seat at the
table so that we can
push the right red shiny button and
and
[Music]
good morning good morning i'm margaret
burns i'm the executive director of the
new hampshire municipal association
um
comments today on on what i've heard and
i'll try not to be too all over the
place um and just and just give you my
my that would be good we were going to
end the 15 minutes i apologize i know
it's a work session i i do appreciate
you allowing me to come up um a few of
the comments i'm concerned about one is
the idea that
different types of funds can just be
used to pay for different types of
services this idea that
property taxes can be segregated off
from other types of fees or funds that
municipalities receive just really
important for the committee to remember
that municipalities fund what they do
through property taxes there's nothing
shocking about them paying for various
services through the money they receive
from collecting property taxes because
that is how they fund their budgets and
that is how they fund what they do
i'm very concerned about the idea that
they can simply use revenue from other
types of fund transfer station to pay
for a certain
item
unless the statute allows for those fees
to be used for that particular
item
as far as the um legislative history of
the bill i'll just comment that you know
representative hill you brought up the
legislative history of bills like this
throughout the years and yes there there
have been many bills like this
throughout the years
specifically with regard to 15-5 the
section that 1033 is dealing with when
we look back at the legislative history
of that bill
and i forget what year it was but i
recently read that legislative history
that legislation that created the
statute we're dealing with now was very
targeted on the executive branch and the
state and its purpose was very simple it
was to restrict entities that receive
state funds
from using state funds to then lobby the
state there was a clear issue that was
recognized there about using the funds
of the state to then just lobby the
state within
municipalities using
municipal funds to advocate or engage
with the state right not to lobby
themselves which was the scenario
scenario that
the original legislation that created
this statute was targeted at
again i appreciate the time i will not
hold you longer with all the bills that
um
anyone else would
you're welcome to make a statement or
or pass or whatever you'd like i don't
know if if you receive what you are
looking for
but we would like to move on to the
yeah on second thought
um
again i get i think what bothers me
about this is the fact that we take a
chunk of money and we give it to
somebody to help us
in whatever ways they see fit and we
agree with them to have help with our
issues
and i have a problem with us now
micromanaging and saying you can do this
and you can't do that
when in fact it's all to our benefit
because we pay
to the municipal association that's
where i'm troubled
i can understand i can understand you're
troubling
on the other side of the spectrum
however there there are a number of
people and i've heard from the other 21
here too
that
that and this may be getting to
representative baxter's point that um
don't feel that the municipal
association reflects their views
and and so um the analogy that one
person brought up to me was
um i wouldn't be happy
if people were taking my tech and i'm
paraphrasing taking my tax money and
putting it into an account for a
candidate that i didn't agree with
any more
than i do in this situation so they're
he was actually bringing up president
trump saying i wouldn't be happy having
my tax dollars being contributed into an
account that would be the reelection for
president trump
and and i wouldn't and i expect on the
other side the same thing they were
saying they were drawing that analogy to
i think that happened to be the new
hampshire school boards association and
saying
those
that organization lobbies against their
interests in in situations as well and
they are not happy with their tax money
going to those organizations that lobby
against their interests with their tax
money
right so that's what i think is behind
all of this thank you very much for that
mr chairman i do know that in the past
um even the communities i represent or
used to represent
um
have had disagreements with positions
the municipal association has taken sure
um nevertheless the word's gotten out
there that
they're working with these issues and it
makes people stop and think and deal
with the issues when they can't
regularly come up here and testify
what i mean by that is that
small towns don't have
the people or the money to come up here
and and wait to be heard
and
that's why i get elected exactly exactly
and um
so
this is where i feel i'm sort of between
a rock and a hard place i i hope
i hope that before we vote on this we
can take a little bit of a break
and thank you sure we have
yeah no we're fine
i'm sorry we are voting
um i'd like to when we get to 10 o'clock
we still have the other bills that we
need to so why don't we why don't we
drop this for now that's what i'd like
to do thank you very much
um
i'm going to close the work session on
10 33 um
and
i think we're just going to jump right
chronologically to
to
1269. um
and i think we're lucky enough to have
an
amendment and uh
and the author of the amendment in the
audience so um representative evil could
you
come up and explain what we have in
front of us here and i assume what we
would have to do is have some committee
member
put on to this amendment
just for logistics purposes but
if you can explain what we have in front
of us and the
in the history of it would be great okay
the long history of it yeah i know
the wonderful world of uh study
committees and commissions um okay for
the record my name is karen ebel um i
represent new london and newbury
um merrimack district five
so um
i think you know the long history of hb
1269 so i won't take you through that
all the time um all now but i have an
amendment here that's based in
almost in almost entirely on an
amendment that representative sheehan
and roulard worked before on which that
is yeah just let me yeah
for a second it's everyone who would
like to look at uh two two zero two two
zero seven eight two eight right sorry
for the record i am discussing that
amendment but i just wanna clarify that
it's based on the amendment largely that
um two representatives on your
committee
were involved in so i'm just going to
like walk you through it i don't want to
belabor anything but on the other hand
it's almost simpler to do it if we just
walk through the amendment
so the first part of the amendment um
makes changes to the section on the
discovery chain uh discovery center
which i gather were requested by the
discovery uh
center um in their testimony that uh
they gave as a follow-up to this bill
let's see
page two and then it's line 26 this
looks like another clarifying change
that came in through dhhs so that's all
fine the the part that i'm really going
to focus on
is starting on page 2
line 33.
is that the definition of study
committee hasn't changed from the
original bill
the definition and and all of that
is is the same
what happened was uh what was removed
was our concept of a joint committee on
committees to review periodically all
the existing statutory commissions so
that part has been
removed so you won't see that
so jumping down i think this is where
things get a little bit different
jumping down on page 2 to line page 3
line 16
we had used i admit it was somewhat of a
clunky phrase but it was trying to be a
descriptified study committee for a
statutory commission you've changed this
this changes that uh term to commission
instead of codified study committee but
otherwise this definition of commission
is identical to the one that we had
before
then if you
so just talking a bit about page three
line 20.
this talks about a commission
requirement that all commissions from
here on out have to have a repeal date
no later than five years from their
creation
the thing here is
there was some i think discussion about
whether or not this provision acted to
basically kill off all
existing statutory commissions that we
have today
and there was i think a little confusion
on that point i talked and and of course
when i wrote it i was thinking
prospectively i wasn't thinking
retroactively
i had quite a discussion with our house
counsel
on this issue and i also talked to ols
and this provision doesn't act
retroactively because that's just not
the way we pass our laws so unless you
really unless the committee wants this
to act retroactively um
they would have to put in specific
information so i'm not sure what
direction the committee wants in that
but i just want to assure you that the
way this is written now this is a
prospective requirement it's not
repealing anything
looking backward
um
so then the next thing i wanted to point
out to the committee
is if you go to
line 24 page 3 this is a change to my
bill
that
it just says
on line 24 the legislative members of
the commission shall constitute a
majority of the commission so that is a
new requirement at this point um you
know you can have one or two
members of the house or the senate on a
commission they don't necessarily have
to
constitute a majority
this was a change that was in
representative sheehan and rulliard's
bill and if they want to explain more
about that i mean i think
thinking back to my time as deputy
speaker and the conversations that we
had one of the issues with commissions
is sort of retaining the power for the
legislators as opposed to all the other
members and so if you have a majority uh
requirement um
it does put a lot more pressure on
legislative membership i mean that's the
decision that you're making so if you
had a 15 person
commission you know you'd have to have
eight members of the legislature but i'm
just pointing that out that's for the
committee's um
consideration so that's new
um
otherwise
um i don't think that there's that much
more new here that's different from what
i had i just
you know i have a continuing concern
that we in some way
make some sort of a routine review of
existing statutory committees and
commissions so that they just don't grow
and like unreviewed for years and years
but i think
what we have here is a situation where
this bill if you go to page
3 line 33
it requires house and senate committees
to go ahead and update the indexes on an
annual basis and provide them to all the
standing committee chairs and so
i honestly think that gives ledge admin
the opportunity and to be honest the
responsibility to look at that updated
list you'll pretty much be able to tell
from the list who's meeting and who
isn't and if you see people or see
groups that aren't really active you can
have them come on an ad hoc basis and
review with them and make a
recommendation on that basis and i would
hope ledge admin would would do that
okay
and then the last thing um
that's in the amendment page four
um
just to take you through the history of
of the marine fisheries
section
when my when our committee on committees
was going through everything um we
worked with fish and game and one of the
things that we recommended that majority
membership on this advisory committee on
marine fisheries
be from the seacoast region as opposed
to requiring all of them
the bill went to the senate the senate
removed that requirement and and i
should just say you talked about it here
at the house you decided to stick with
that recommendation in the original bill
it went to the senate the senate removed
it
so when i reintroduced the bill i didn't
include it in the original hb 1269.
at your previous meeting which
unfortunately i was unable to attend i
understand that you decided you want to
put this requirement back in
and my suggestion was that we try to put
together some language that reflects the
discussions that were going on over in
the senate
so there were a couple of things um that
came out of a letter that i provided
to
i think chair hill and and
representative sheehan and rulliard
they were concerned that a majority of
the membership including the alternate
if we were going to go that route
be from the seacoast region
they really were concerned that there be
a requirement that everybody go on
that's on this advisory committee have
expertise in marine fisheries i put that
in here
my concern was they wanted everybody
from the seacoast region but seacoast
region isn't defined anywhere and so
what i did was i referred to a
definition of tidewater towns which
appears earlier in
in the rsas
so i'm hoping
that this will be
acceptable going forward as a as a sort
of a compromised position on trying to
have the membership of the advisory
committee
come from that representation other than
just the tidewater towns great so that's
that's sort of the end of it
i did i talked a lot to
house counsel cnc and if there's
clarifications that he needs to make or
the house clerk or anybody else
go for it will you take questions i
yes representative
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you very much represent for doing this
and i want to thank
all the people on both sides of the
aisle who've worked so hard to bring
this to where it is today i'm
particularly interested in and page 3
lines 23 uh 20 rather through
about 24 25. um
i think that was critical
to this entire
uh piece of legislation and
the wording is greatly improved this is
wonderful and i thank you so much okay
that's nice to hear all right um
i have one
item that um well in addition to
thanking you for all your work on this
um it's the job that never ends no no it
just never ends we'll be glad when this
is over i wanted to also make sure that
um
the conversation um about
the missing section f um is that uh is
that something okay so the thing the
thing is um i don't know
the
the missing okay the missing section app
um like area 50 yeah i know i mean i
think the thing was
i don't even know um how many of the
members know about the missing section f
if they didn't have um representative
sheehan's
amendment because that's where it showed
up so i don't i don't know why i don't
know if they do i've lost okay so so
they're ready i know
uh so the reason that came up again
page 3 line 20 to 22.
so the reason that that came up is that
there was some discussion about this
section acting retroactively to repeal
all statutory commissions
and
if you did that
that
would end up
being a situation where everybody who
wanted to have their terms extended
would have to
and then what happened was there was a
discussion of the groups that really
should be excluded from an automatic
repeal if you look retroactively
and so um working with representative
umberger there was a list developed that
became the famous section f
that
i just kept looking at it and i looked
at our definition of commission and so
that's why
you know i finally just said okay i'm
going back to the source i'm going back
to our house council jim cianci from
whence a lot of these provisions uh came
and i said are i'm confused on what is
really a commission for purposes of this
bill and he said well we're focusing on
things that study and what was listed in
the famous section f was like the joint
was like jalcar
the fiscal committee things like that
none of those things are actually study
committees so what we did was
we
removed section f
from uh representative sheehan's
amendment and what you have before you
is basically um
a replication of what
you guys had done before right but it
took a long time to get there
it did and and as it was pointed out to
me and i'd just like to throw this on
the record it it came down to
the definition that shows on page three
between lines 16 and 19 right and it
talked about
those
those that are showing there were
established those entities that were
established by the general court and
codified in
rsas for the specific term to study for
for a specific term of time to study
and otherwise address a specific issue
and those didn't apply to
section f right those those committees
that were listed in section f right and
i and i guess the only other point to
add there is if this provision is not
acting retroactively
you don't have to be as concerned about
excluding things from the retroactive
action
but that's again i'm just putting that
out there for the committee if you do
want retroactive action this this
provision doesn't do that it has to be
more specific right
i'm good anyone else have
further comments questions concerns
you're off the hook thank you very much
um do you can you just introduce this
with my name or should i ask ols to add
a member of your committee that this is
fine
this is fine we're getting the thumbs up
from the house clerk so okay we're good
um but thank you for pointing that out
um i think that closes the conversation
on
this unless anyone has anything else
they want to discuss on 1269
good
closing that
um now i see
um
rich lambert ready to talk about an
amendment for
okay
do we have no we don't have that
amendment as yet correct we do you
did it get past that here it is great
you're off the hook too
um it would be nice however if you could
take the
the witness stand and we can talk about
change in plants hold just a second um
so here's um this is probably
a little inside baseball stuff but um we
didn't list
this bill number
on in the calendar as part of the work
session
so it was just pointed out to me that it
would be inappropriate to bring up the
work session bring up this bill in this
work session but we can
if we go into executive session
so you had asked for five or ten minutes
for um
conversation for your
and and yeah we probably are ready for a
short break so if we could take 10
minutes good
10 minutes or so and then we'll come
back and go into executive session and
then we'll talk about this bill in the
executive session okay
thanks very much
thank you yeah
10 15
10 15 good
oh that's fine okay good um can i meet
the executive session
and in order to get uh
mr lambert back to work um
i'm going to suggest we open the exec
session on
house bill 13.
and
would you like to explain the amendment
to us please
thank you yeah we need to get it on the
record
um this is
um
for those
we actually now have a
substitute we need to thank for coming
in uh representative burke
is in for
uh
representative greene
so everyone's aware
um
this is uh house bill 1368 uh executive
session um an act
rec uh relative to recusal by members of
the general court for conflicts of
interest
the prime sponsor had mentioned that an
amendment was needed
during testimony and that's what we're
here we have in front of us
somewhere
what was that
this one
it's amendment 2022 zero seven
nine four h
just to clarify um will you also make
announcements if you have received any
online support or opposed
that
you
i can do that right now so
on the online
there were two people in support of this
mr lambert um
i think you need to push the button so
the little red light lights up of course
there you go
i am
staffed the ethics committee as the
executive administrator and in that
capacity i can't advocate for
legislation or state any sort of
opinions on policy but i can try to
explain things objectively
questions
i think the chairman gordon
representative gordon explained
how the bill came about and why based on
past
or fairly recent complaints
and some advisory opinions where
it was felt that this whole issue needs
to be clarified in terms of when
disclosure is not enough but recusal
might be required
when a legislator has a conflict of
interest
and the the amendment seeks to clarify
some points that um aspects that needed
clarification
um
which is what he um and you discussed at
so
currently there's
two levels of conflict of interest one
you address by filling out the
declaration of intent form which is now
every two years it has all those
categories if you're you know in banking
or real estate or an attorney you
put that information on the form
and generally that is enough to do
um in terms of
action required to be taken
um unless
the um conflict is more
is greater to you than other people in
that group so if there's a bill that
comes along that affects you as an
attorney more than other attorneys you
would then have to go and file a
declaration of intent form and decide
whether to participate or not
this would impose another level
where if you have a substantially
greater benefit or detriment that could
occur from the bill you would have to
recuse
and that grew out of
a complaint that
occurred a few years ago
and
and and that's is that the sum and
substance of the changes in this
amendment yes
would you be willing to take questions
yes
does the committee have questions
i have a couple um
oh representative wall i didn't see your
phone i'm sorry go you go you go no
okay thank you very much rich um for
putting my name on this
uh what
i believe this is not a question this is
a comment if i may mr chairman sure uh
what this amendment does is it clarifies
the
uh guidelines under which or the law
actually will be under which a person
would recuse from a particular
bill that we're working on and one
example i have
is from
one of the committees i worked on we had
several people who owned rental
properties and did not disclose that to
begin with
and then acted in ways in legislation
that benefited them when it came to
landlord tenant issues and this caused
some concern for several years and what
this amendment does if you look at line
uh roman numeral four it
clarifies under um
when it as to when a person needs to
recuse if there's a conflict of interest
and that person is not able to be
objective in their voting which is
already stated in our ethics booklets
that we have they must recuse
and right now there's a great deal of
concern among a number of house members
because they don't know when they should
or should not recuse
so this just helps to clarify that
situation what this does it works back
to back well that's
already in our booklet
maybe rich can you i i'm trying to grab
in the booklet where it says a person
needs to um if they benefit more than
someone else from
a particular
issue
say if they're a landlord and they're
going to benefit more than the average
person we're in here i think i've got it
under a conflict of interest procedure
on page 12 when a legislator becomes
aware that a conflict of interest exists
or may exist and the conditions set
forth in paragraph two and it goes on
and on and most people don't even look
at this booklet and i think that's part
of why we have a problem
they need to declare
that they have an interest in this
and then they have to declare whether or
not they intend to participate if a
person can't be objective then they must
okay yeah that's great um
i think it is
good to um
more clearly spell out the language in
in uh in simpler language
legislators are
are uh
are busy with their own lives and with
this to read a booklet uh quite frankly
to see what what um
relates to them
i've always had difficulty with this and
that's why i've always for for freshman
members um
it's a great resource to go and and talk
to mr lambert and ask him questions um
in advance of of an issue um
i have personal knowledge of that
but i also have
in relation to the general
bill as it as it was do you have a copy
of the original bill i do as well as the
amendment yes
on uh page well i guess it's one line
24.
there was there was a section uh
starting with has a special interest in
the official legislative activity
there are
this is replete with with um
areas
of descriptive sentences special
interest
and
when it deals with
whether you have a conflict of interest
well is that a special interest that i
have um
it's confusing as i'll get out for
everyone i think um it is for me anyway
i'll say
but but special interest is mentioned
there
and then on the top of page two
we we crossed out special
interest and made it financial interest
so conflict of interest means the
condition in which a legislator has a
financial
interest or a non-financial does that
mean special interest doesn't exist
anymore or does it exist still it's been
redefined
in
2014 and 15 there was a study commission
on the ethics laws
and they made some changes and that was
one of them
actually so this will go back to the
language which existed from the
beginning from 1991 up to
uh where there were was a financial
interest in those days conflict of
interest was solely a financial interest
that commission wanted to talked about
recusal but didn't go there instead they
increased the level of conflict of
interest and what you need to do about
it
and they added this other category of
non-financial interest
which would be if someone's on the board
of directors and as a fiduciary
responsibility to
their entity
um so that was added to it and also
there was more disclosure added
in 2015 um in terms of
making a requirement to make a verbal
disclosure
but that's when this term special
interest was created and it probably
confused things further
um then because it was special interest
was then a conflict of interest and
conflict of interest was a financial
interest or
a non-financial special interest
personal interest so
this goes back to making a little less
complicated in that respect one would
hope
but
this is what i'm you know i i see puzzle
looks
out there i see puzzle looks in here um
this is what we're
this is what we're dealing with
it's very hard for someone
who's not
conversant
in in these areas or
it's just not on the radar of a lot of
people i think i've only heard
three times in house session this year
where someone has recused themselves
from a vote well
a lot of averages tell you that that
can't be right you know and that tells
me that there's still a problem um of
understanding
the process maybe even if they
understand that they have a a conflict
they don't know what to do about it i
think is still the case
some people are nodding here i to go
further i
i was always under the impression um or
had it in my head and because i heard
from
you know my as a freshman
legislator from my mentors that only if
your
situation
is different than anyone else in that
same category if you're getting some
added benefit that others aren't and so
i see some of that language here
on
in the new language
starting on on line 10 of page two
but it talks about um
when it it's dealing with a business
um
so
under the and i don't see it when it's
an individual i see in the new language
and it talks on page on line 15 which is
substantially greater than the benefit
or detriment which would accrue to a
business clients or organization in
general i don't see that phrase
when
we're talking specifically about you
know in a where it says we're a
legislator a household member i don't
see anything that says
that substantially greater than a
benefit or detriment which could accrue
to business
that that confuses me that we're only
seemingly talking about
the business relationship not the
personal relationship
am i wrong
i thought that maybe another few words
could have been added
i should have shared this with chairman
gordon but
if you look at
toward the end of that sentence which is
a long sentence
it is a long sentence or it says
the next to last line the benefit of
detriment which would accrue
to
businesses
if you added the legislator or a
legislators household member
and or or
or to
the businesses
and this would be
the thing is probably what needs to be
described better as what constitutes a
substantially greater
conflict
and that could be worked out with the
ethics guidelines
where
sort of like where rules ministry rules
will be more more specific than a law
in this case
the guidelines are where
conflicts of interest and the process of
dealing with them is defined and that
those are adopted by the committee and
then sent to the house and senate for
approval so you would be voting on
anything like that again
in a different form
but
i think that this paragraph in fact i
know from speaking with
representative gordon this was intended
to also include the individual
because it starts out that way
it talks about benefit or detriment to
the legislator or legislators household
member
so when it gets down to the last
phrase
this edition would clarify it further
perhaps
right because it does talk about the
legislator legislators household member
and then it says or
to produce a benefit or detriment
to business client so it doesn't seem
i don't know how you feel but but i feel
there's still work to be done but you're
you're on thank you mr chairman and
thank you rich for all your work you're
doing on this for years
i have asked
that we condense our booklet into
something like what the executive branch
has it should be on a piece of paper
like this it should be well like a
little palm card thing
one side you can do this and the other
you can't do that we have not gotten to
that point yet i do know
that it is hard for people to understand
what we have without conferring with
rich
that
most people don't even open the booklet
to look at it
and if they do they don't understand it
because
it requires cross-referencing in some
parts
the attempt with this was to help
clarify one small section which is when
a person should recuse
and that's where that little thing would
be handy you know you can do this you
can do this but whoops don't and if you
do have to then you should go here and
do this and fill out this form or
something like that so i i understand
the confusion on this um i respect the
work that's been done i did not write
this amendment
chairman gordon did it and um he did
clean up the bill uh the bill was weak
and confusing and this does clarify i'm
particularly
looking at lines 13-16
as to when recusal is required
um but i can see where some people don't
understand that either
so
i do support this but i understand there
are still questions
are there any further comments questions
concerns
i'd be willing to accept emotion from
you if you would like to since your name
is on it
well
okay i would love to do ought to pass
but i think because of what i'm hearing
here that we ought to go into interim
study so i move interim study mr
chairman
there a second
i'll move second sure we have a
motion to interim study
house bill
1368.
we would have to accept
or reject the amendment
before
because there's no such thing really
though as interim study as amended so
interim study we can certainly take this
up i i think this is a true
interim study that we're talking about
so that we would be
looking it through with representative
gordon and others well i don't know mr
chairman if the committee has officially
accepted the amendment yet
and if because we can't do it on an
amendment right now if we set the
amendment aside
and then do the interim study and
include that i i think that i think the
way to move forward that's what we'll do
um
the motion on the floor is interim study
on
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
i'm clear
thanks
representative roulard
yes
representative osborne
representative bert yes
the clerk votes yes
representative simon yes
representative vanda castille yes
representative wallace yes
representative baxter yes
representative wall yes
representative richards
yes
representative espia
representative schultz
yes
representative hill
13-0
13-0 13-0
15-0
13 yeah
i thought you said 15. no 13. okay
yep 13-0
um mr chairman i i i ask that this go on
the consent calendar
without objection
janet we'll do the blurb
right
thank you mr lambert um appreciate all
your assistance welcome representative
um
1269 house bill 1269 will take up um
and this is the second to last bill we
have
still 13 right okay
um
give us a minute here to reset and
we're good
um
house bill
1269 dealing with certain legislative
i would entertain a motion
are you going to do the amendment first
nope
go
i would move up to the pass thank you
second second second by representative
expedia
nope this is the bill and now the bill
is open to further amendment
i would
look to representative simon for
thank you
yeah mr chair i would move uh to pass on
8 2 h
representative expedia
seconds the motion would you like to
speak to the amendment motion
um i think
people have put in a lot of work that
most of us aren't really interested in
doing on this particular topic although
we're all grateful for the work that
they've done because i think it's an
important uh issue
and uh
just for the sake of the amount of work
that it takes to oversee these
committees and to staff these committees
um
you know putting some sort of expected
repeal date on them uh so that they
don't just stay on the books um
kind of ineffectively i think is is the
right way to go um
so for those reasons i'll move out to
pass on this
representative of this media i just echo
those um those comments made by
representative simon i think this was a
lot of work and i appreciate and applaud
representative evil representative
roulard representative she and everybody
who put work into making this a good
bill um
hopefully we can get across the finish
line thank you very much any further
comments on the amendment this is on the
amendment zero seven eight two h
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
representative roulard yes
representative osborne
representative bert
yes
clerk votes yes
representative simon yes
representative vanda castille
representative wallace yes
representative baxter yes representative
wall yes
representative richards
yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz
yes
representative hill
having passed 13-0 we now have an ought
to pass as amended
is there further discussion on
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
representative roulard
yes
representative osborne
representative burke
yes
clerk boasts yes
representative simon
yes representative vanda castille yes
representative wallace yes
representative baxter yes
representative richards
this is ought to pass
no that was the bill as amended yeah as
amended okay
okay
representative spedia yes
representative schultz yes
representative hill
yes
we would like to
reconsider the vote on
yes yes so that is it just changed that
too
to zero yes thirteen to zero
um
i would
entertain consent
um
house bill
[Music]
12.69 is that what that is yep 1269 um
um
you'll we'll work on the blurb
i apologize for that i was writing on
the previous bill thank you
it was it wasn't i thought it might have
been an ethics issue and you're accusing
yourself
i was confused all right um
so that closes the executive session on
house bill 1269 we will open the
executive session on house bill 1033
fn
and
seek
a motion
representative simon thank you mr chair
i'll move out to pass on hp 1033
representative simon moves out to pass
on house bill 1033
second oh second thank you
representative sheehan
oil machine we've got going here um the
bill is open to further amendment um i
would
recognize representative simon
thank you mr chair i would move out to
0805 h has been moved
seconded by
uh moved
simon
this is on the amendment is there any
further discussion on the amendment
representative simon
uh yeah i mean this amendment simply
clarifies um
what we're talking about as far as the
origination of the funds and and makes
the bill better um so i would just move
out to pass on on this amendment thank
you representative simon any further
comments representative wall thank you
mr chairman i agree that the amendment
does improve
but
thank you representative wall any
further comments
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the role on house bill on the amendment
to house bill 1033
2022-0
h
representative roulard yes
representative osborne
representative bert yes
clerk votes yes
representative simon yes representative
vanda castille
representative wallace yes
representative baxter yes
representative richards yes
representative espedia
representative schultz yes
representative hill yes
13-0
13-0 uh the bill is the amendment
five zero zero eight zero five h passes
bill is open to further amendment
representative simon
thank you mr chair i would move um i'll
to pass on amendment two zero two two
dash zero seven four three h
representative simon moves ought to pass
on zero seven four three h
is there a second
second
second by representative sheehan
representative simon would you like to
speak to your motion
uh yes thank you mr chair um
i guess i would just say that if this
bill is to make it all the way through
and become law this amendment um
will clarify
communication um to the respective
parties that are on the receiving end of
this um what their what their role is um
so that
municipalities or towns or school boards
or whatever uh don't inadvertently
go against go against the law this will
this will be will clearly communicate to
them in the section of the law that they
pay attention to uh what the
expectations are so that we're not
setting people up for
misinform being misinformed of the
responsibility thank you representative
simon um any further comments
i will just say that i think
this amendment
is probably the most important because
it makes
um people aware
of of the existing situation
as well as any future
changes to
prohibitions on purchasing lobbying
services
and it makes them aware by putting it in
the section that pertains to their
own
area of interest
it makes it very hard when you have to
go searching for
something within the rsas
and this would put it in their own
respective section which i think is a
a logical move forward
um
with that i seeing no other comments i
will ask the clerk to call the role
representative roulard yes
representative osborne
representative burke yes
eric votes yes
representative simon yes
representative van de castille
representative wallace yes
representative baxter yes representative
yes
representative espedia yes
representative schultz
so now we have and ought to pass as
amended
on
is there any further comment on house
bill
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the roll
representative roulard yes
representative osborne
representative bert yes eric voties
representative simon yes representative
vanda castille
representative wallace yes
representative baxter yes representative
wall no
representative richards no
representative expedia no
representative schultz no
representative hill
yes
9-4
ought to pass as amended uh passes nine
votes to four
i
am assuming there will be a minority
report um i will help representative
simon with
the majority committee report um you'll
let me know if there's going to be a
minority report
okay
believe it or not folks that ends our
work not only today but
for this half of the session we've exact
26 bills i think um
in relatively short order and and i
think most went on consent which is
a lovely thing
mr chair so we don't have any second
committee bills
um i haven't seen any as yet great yep
um
i'm not wishing anything on anyone here
but uh but i don't i don't think we'll
see committee second committee bills uh
generally this this committee does not
but uh that that doesn't necessarily
hold true for the future um as far as i
know we are all set i wanted to thank
our
fine substitute for the day
and tell you all that for now
i've got i've got reports for
everything
i don't have minority reports for prior
bills if you're willing if you want to
submit them you're welcome to if you
don't they'll go in without the minority
report
um representative wall i want to thank
you mr chairman for guiding us through
all these bills and getting us through
so
amiably
and so efficiently
can you tell us what you know about our
next house session oh yes thank you very
much
um
march 10th is the next
um and march 10th uh
believe it or not we will be in rep's
hall
so um
your for some the mileage goes down for
some the miles she goes back up again
who knows um but it is uh march 10th
there is all it it also appears like
there may be a day the following week as
well but that has not been as clearly
established in
to my satisfaction so i won't even start
rumors that way
um
but that was why we needed to have
things in as quickly as we did and uh
and everyone did a great job getting
i don't know
if if people are planning to speak on
on bills
that we have that aren't on consent
i would appreciate hearing
it has to come through me anyway so um
let me know
and um and that's about all i have for
you um
anything else that comes up everyone has
my
my cell number give me a call um now
that we're not dealing with the speed
limit on winnipesaukee anymore my phone
doesn't get as clogged up so
[Music]
you should be able to get through to me
um
but other than that i'm all set anybody
else have anything else we
are closed until we start seeing
senate bills that come over
oh sorry
thanks bud yes any time he realized i
heard it was your committee i was like
oh of course i would come up you
realized you realized that 10 33 right i
now why did they tell me to behave up
here
here so this is the side by side that
jennifer put together from prior times
representative castile this was your
blur
you